hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host John Carroll the
world we live in today I don't think
anyone can argue is suffused with
numbers with data with information data
and information come at us from all
directions right whether we're reading
newspaper or magazine looking something
online watching TV scientific papers and
the thing about numbers and data is that
they have this Aura of objectivity right
like there's a number you can't argue
with it it's giving you some information
that could be false but as long as the
information is reliable it's telling you
something objective about the world but
the reality is that the way that we
present that information visually
whether it's in literal series of
numbers or a chart or a graph or
whatever matters it affects how we
process the information what seems
important to us what is it that we
notice what is it that we care about so
sometimes you want to do your best I
hope that usually you want to do your
best at conveying information clearly
and vividly and concisely sometimes
maybe you want to FIB a little bit right
and hide the parts of the information
that you're not that proud of the one
way or the other it matters how it is
presented so the Art and Science of
presenting information is very important
in the modern world and today's guest is
the guy when it comes to the display of
quantitative information Edward tufty uh
is uh the author of the classic book
namely the visual display of
quantitative information they're really
pioneering texts that help people
understand the importance of graphs and
charts and how they are presented in the
way to do it well and since then he's
continued to try to educate as many
people as possible about thinking
clearly and presenting those thoughts
clearly in a visual form he has a new
book out called seeing with fresh eyes
meaning space data and Truth and One
once again it's it's an exploration not
just of how to present information but
the meaningfulness of that information
one of the big things that Edward pushes
is that the origins of quantitative
information as a way of talking about
things you can trace back to let's say
Galileo for example and it's not just a
new way of presenting information but a
new way of thinking a new way of arguing
for a conclusion based on evidence
rather than just words giving you an
argument a shift from rationalism to
empiricism if you like and in the new
book we talks a lot about truth there's
a lot of physics diagrams in there as
well as a lot of works of art which give
you a different kind of Truth so it's a
real pleasure to talk to someone who is
is truly a major transformative figure
in their field and just listen to the
wisdom that he has to offer so let's go
[Music]
thank you
welcome to the mindscape podcast uh
welcome good I do want to start with the
sort of obvious caveat slash apology
which is that you're the World's expert
in data visualization and we're doing an
audio only podcast so I I do understand
that it'll be even nicer if you could
you know point to things but we'll have
people check out your books and so forth
you have a new book out why don't you
why don't we give you that chance to
mention that okay
um it's volume Five in this series that
started in 1983 with the visual display
of quantitative information and this is
the fifth book of the title is quite
immodest hmm clean with fresh eyes
meaning space data truth
and I can't think of a grander title but
I I kind of set it as a goal as I was
writing and I had to talk about all this
stuff with this this the the title and
um that's exactly what it's about yeah
it's uh redesigning everything sentences
paragraphs Feynman diagrams everything
sculpture
um and um uh that requires uh the scene
with with fresh eyes
um I have I open the book with a a
little bit of free verse
um which kind of describes it and also
describes me if it's all right please
would love it
um this is a free verse it's called The
Thinking eye to see the ordinary so
intensely
that the ordinary becomes extraordinary
becoming so focused so specific about
something
that'll become something other than what
it ordinarily is always on
thinking I see
intensely actively skeptically
scanned globally
focused locally see at varying scales of
space and time
approximating ways through Multiplicity
detecting how things happen move act
interact seeing with fresh eyes vacation
eyes I love that I love the location
eyes that we have about you know the
first five days at a place it just seems
so like a wonderful fresh fresh shot
um seeing with fresh eyes vacation Eyes
unhindered by self-confirming words
models expectations not seeing something
different is not seeing anything at all
Grace Hopper saying the most dangerous
phrase in the language is we've always
done it this way
staying in Optical experiences
forgetting the name of what one sees
this is a very important idea about
seeing with your odds not seeing with
your with words
once you have the words it's impossible
to see around them it's very important
and sculpture for example if you uh if
you walk out and see a a big thing and
people say oh it looks like Stonehenge
or it looks like this or it looks like
it was it so somebody bought for a
million euros in Zurich the last week at
an auction you can't see it any other
way and so that that's this the scene is
God would be free of words because the
words will dominate what you see so
staying an optical experience forgetting
the name of what one sees laughing
playful Oz shut up and look if you see
something say nothing
defamiliarize decontextualize
recontextualize reform remodel thinking
eyes are of this world empirical
specific practical self-aware asking
disbelieving challenging
making the familiar unfamiliar how do
you I they really know that there's a
little stack list in the middle how do
in a sentence stand vertical you either
really know that how could you either
possibly ever know that that is how
could you design a research you know
could you even design a piece of
research that will enable you to own it
thinking eyes reason
intensely about what they see reason
about verbs links mechanisms connections
Dynamics reason about what things do not
what things are named reason across
multiple time Horizons now
then forever
name rename remodel thinking eyes
compare model choose doubt decide
compare again thinking eyes act make
something of seeing and reasoning
discover produce construct write a
report make an artwork teach a class
have an Insight understand explain show
get on with it to produce construct
model
remodel to act is essential it is a
difference between spectator
and player between consumer and producer
between art chat versus artwork anecdote
versus evidence process versus outcome
retrospective versus prospective
presentations pitching versus
demonstrations comparing Craig Venter
saying good ideas are a dime a dozen for
a smart person what distinguishes good
from great is how an idea is executed
how it becomes reality
thinking ideas thinking eyes identify
know celebrate Excellence forever
Universal knowledge Gathering
consequences say staying in place beyond
memories and precision seeing learning
doing doubting are the meaning of
intelligent life
I like that thank you I feel like I
should applaud a little bit for the
performance thank you uh but you know
I'll say that I love the word truth
appearing in your subtitle because
that's what hit me over and over again
sort of reading through all your books
over the decades and thinking about what
you're doing
there's the sort of
down to earth operational side of making
a beautiful chart and then there's the
much more profound question of
discovering truth presenting it and
conveying it and that's really the
motivating factor yeah
it's uh is what it's all about
um it's uh
in any good reporter presentation it's
about the uh about the content and The
credibility
uh it's not about whether you should do
a certain Motif or use a certain method
it's about the content and the truth of
it the credibility uh and that's what
that's what's going on an information
exchange
um and this this kind of stuff about the
coding for visualization and all that I
regard that as Plumbing
um
it's Plumbing basically and the the the
reason we're having the reading that
that research report or that we're
having this meeting is to reason about
content and assess The credibility of
the material that's what that's the
fundamental thing it's it's all about
and all the kinds of things I did early
on there was this
um concern with
um was getting it right getting it true
uh but it's really as I've become more
General and applying to more and more
things uh truth comes right along with
it
and you know the plumbing May differ but
it's content and then are are they say
something true
I have a long chapter on medical
research in the new book and
it's widely agreed
by editors of the online Journal of
Medicine
by editors of the Lancet and by the
famous skeptic John ionitis at Stanford
that most published medical research
findings are false and the debate isn't
over whether that's that statement is
true or false the debate over
is the debate is over the word most
[Laughter]
and so in a field
uh it appears to be at least 50 percent
in medical published medical research
and this is by people who've been
editors of journals yeah
um and it varies by by Fields
um in in some Fields I I
um I I did the ignoble prize Awards this
this year love those yeah yeah and um I
did 24 jargon words about
um cognitive psychology and then you
have seven short words at this I went
through the jargama parameters and blah
blah blah and so on and then the the
punch line is um that the first day in
the class in cognitive psychology the
professor says
um half of the findings in our textbook
are false we just don't know which half
and and so it's a it's it's part of the
failure to replicate the replication
process uh thing science has it easy uh
um rocket science compared to social
science or even medical Sciences is easy
because you've got a guarantee of the
truth there is truth there are the laws
of nature and that makes it easy you
know there is truth you don't even know
whether truth exists for the you know
about a lot of public personal uh people
people things uh or medical medical
things and so um uh rocket science is
easy I say it all the time I tell people
that physics is the easiest science
that's why it's so intimidating because
it's so easy we've learned so much about
the physical world it's extraordinary as
and also the only thing that's Universal
it's through everywhere that's I mean
just out that's out of this world
so let me give let me let's make sure
that uh the people the the tiny
percentage of listeners who aren't
already familiar with your work sort of
get the thrust of it right from the
start I mean you work at the
intersection of data and design and you
know design is a is a tricky thing do
you have any any training in design or
is this something that you just built up
along the way uh or do you stumble into
it or was that a goal all along in your
career
um my parents my mother was a professor
of English
uh and I did scholar scholarly work on
the 17th century
but she also
wrote a book which I then published I
I'm a self-publisher I published my
mother's book called syntax's Style
um it's called The Artful sentences
syntax as Style and so that was kind of
the word part in my home my father was a
civil engineer which was a very applied
science there you go outdoors and that
helped me a lot of my sculpture of
course and they both could really see
well
I don't know where that came from uh but
they could really notice things and see
well and I was taught to see well uh
both in reading things and and reading
poetry and looking at pictures and
talking to my mother but also being
outdoors with my father and so we'd be
take a vacation we drive toward Hoover
Dam in the middle of on the Colorado
River and study the dam because my
father was in civil engineer or every
time it rained we would go out driving
to see the storm range salary up the
wrong way so it was a intense scene was
just part of it interesting
um and I married the famous graphic
designer in the druckery it was
Professor Yale and uh risdi and uh the
University of Arts in Philadelphia
and um I I learned a lot from her
um and I found design very easy and
within uh as soon as I did my book on
visual display I was teaching in the
Yale graduate school on in design
okay so it probably was good enough
didn't need to have a degree uh because
I had done the design for the books
right by working with a book designer
and the rest of the books I've designed
in Tara and myself and frankly
I found designs very easy hmm
um I think it was because of my verbal
skills uh I think many designers are
like violinists or
um there's a kind of innate quality of
seeing and working with your hands and
making things
and it's not so much it's a kind of
almost a physical performance not so
much an intellectual performance there's
a real difference there it's a seeing
performance not a word performance
that's a better way to put it and I'm
not
um I'm
um I'm a a b-plus in a lot of different
fields I'm I'm an A plus in in
visualization but a lot of the subfields
like writing design uh statistical work
and all this I'm
um I I could uh probably teach a you
know introductory course you know a good
school it's not uh and and I can use but
I have these tools that I can use you
know all the time that I I like I can do
everything myself within myself yeah wow
so the books I designed myself I publish
them myself I love the craft and the the
former craft of deuts books yeah with
the computer screen it's not like that
anymore uh
and so it just somehow came in this odd
package of genetics and school
and never specializing right that was
that's actually that was the key thing I
got a Bachelor's and master's degree in
statistics from Stanford PhD in
political science at Yale I was a a good
a good political scientist I was a full
Professor by age 31 at uh at Princeton
in political science but it was
quantitative I think it was over the
graphics you know more and more up
Saturday the politics Department you
know why I'm socially doing this and
muscle movements Graphics stuff and I
think I always wanted to be a professor
you know from about age 12 on
but I have yet to discover
a professor of what right uh I've I've
thought I thought in the law school I
taught in design I had tenure and public
affairs at Princeton I had appointments
and statistics
um and maybe like it's because I have a
short attention span but I loved going
into a discipline and looting it not not
getting a a
you know a degree in it but rather
looting what was useful for me and
I get in The Fairly different posture
when I talk to people in other fields
who were and I've always been attracted
by X once by hanging around excellent
professors when I was a student
regardless of what they were excellent
at uh and seeing how they think and just
being with some most happy and it's the
only time I really shut up
it's one
you know in this environment where
there's all this stuff to be learned and
I just say interesting and oh that's
interesting and maybe say you know guide
them slightly ever maybe say why is that
once or twice every few minutes but I
just love that kind of discussion where
I have no responsibility except to
listen and guide it just enough to to do
it and um it's I think when I'm happiest
well I'm I'm a stranger in all these
contacts but I'm so taken by it and
because I did the data stuff I could I
could play on just about everybody's
backyard so let me let me if it's okay
get down to some nitty-gritty because I
do want to make sure that every uh
listener to the podcast comes away
making slightly better charts than they
did coming in I mean we live in a world
where there's graphics and and data
visualization all over the place this is
probably an unfair question but what do
you think is the biggest flaw or the
most common mistake in how people make
charts and and present their data these
days Multiplicity
okay
they um try five times five different
Graphics or maybe ten they have a
programmer hmm it does us something
special
and they cherry pick the results and
my first piece of advice to any
researcher is use utterly conventional
Graphics that are in the very best very
best graphics in your field
and you specify those Graphics in
advance
you can't search through you can't
cherry pick things are so bad that in
medical research in Syria in clinical
trials rcts randomized con uh
trials
now you have to specify their Graphics
before they see the data wow because
everybody was cheating
cherry picking
because most everybody is Doctor
confirmation bias sure all researchers
are have have a little bit of
confirmation bias and of course they do
the real giveaway is that in the the
study is cheated is that they'll have an
unusual custom graphic hmm interesting
not a conventional graphic and they're
so proud of it that the title of work
paper is
ending metastasizing and cancer
by the use of artificial deep
intelligence six-point CP 2. so they're
pitching their finding and their
contribution that they've also made to
graphical things
that is the sign of a fraud and somebody
who's cheating if they have any kind of
decent substance thing finding the data
doesn't matter the plumbing they're
trying to say well I brought this thing
into the field like I used to refereed
all kinds of of papers people would say
graphics for
sociologists graphics for psychology you
know and they would you know think what
[__] you know
it's it's uh
um the principles of Graphics are the
are
in are don't come from the feel they
come from the problem the data problem
to be done right and so you do whatever
it takes in any field you know what
Graphics did you use in Psychology
whatever it takes is the answer
no not that we have some kind of special
things so the the the giveaway is an
unusual uh charting method often custom
so are you thinking about something like
you know pie charts versus histograms
versus line charts is that that the
difference of choices that we're
thinking of here no we're thinking of of
scientists more scientific serious
things okay what are the kinds of
choices that you're saying people make
uh to sort of cheat a little bit
oh
um they take uh they they put things on
they put a y on a logarithmic scale ah
okay yeah they that that's the the
um and they're good they're good reasons
usually for it but not always
um if there's a doubt they should show
both that's how you get around it that
your findings survive both
Transformations
um it's uh the conventionality is also
good because the person has come there
to learn about uh that that the cancer
can metastasizing can be stopped they
haven't come to learn about your your
graphic right and you want to minimize
you want them to to your readers to see
the data instantly not decode a graphic
not have little color codes like R does
endlessly
um python is better on that
um
and so use conventional things just as
you used there's all kinds of
conventions about the language that you
use in published papers they're
conventional things let's get you know
get it all get all that out of the way
and that now allows cross resource
comparisons
um and people who are shopping around
for something new or thinking they're
making a contribution
look Don knuth did it 25 years ago okay
okay
that's true that's true of everything by
the way yeah he did my sparklines which
I was so proud of he did something
called Skyline skylines like little
things came up silhouette skylines you
know online an inline graphic and what
really was 25 years before my smartphone
but it's true everybody will once they
hear that but I was saying yeah that's
right I mean maybe tell people what A
sparkline is for those who haven't heard
of it it's an inline graphic so it's uh
uh like a word in line and it has a
resolution of typography which is an
intense resolution
the letters so it's very high data and
it's embedded in the text itself uh and
shows lots lots of it and it's perfectly
readable
and it's the highest stress if if you
can operate at a graphic at the
resolution of typography you're in the
big leagues and so that's the metaphor
instead of a word it's a graphic it's
words like sized it's built right in
um and and you have a bunch of these and
now you have what's called a table uh of
lines like that with consisting of words
and numbers and also maybe little tiny
images
I first got the idea from Galileo pretty
good quite important a lot of ideas for
when he discovered uh the rings of
Saturn and he says Saturn looks like
this and there's this little Charming
picture little drawing line drawing that
the printer had to tack through out of
the lead make a special Saturn letter
there and you can see how it's kind of
done roughly and this it says Galway
also Saturn looks like this
and two lines later he says on a cloudy
night it looks like that so comparison
of of a clear and cloudy and you could
you know there was a difference and it's
right there in front of you and it's
perfect you don't need it the egg that's
working that's you know you can barely
see on himself and I I that's showing up
and kind of seek quietly I think all
five of my books I have gallons yeah
because it is so wonderful and it's such
a visual portion and and just seeing and
he is the person who saw
more than seen he said we now have the
evidence of the eye not the evidence of
the church sitting around in armchairs
parsing Aristotle and parsing the Bible
about astronomy and Galileo knows
exactly what's happening says we now
have the evidence of the eye we have
visible certainty
and ding ding now all about truth and
and empiricism right I mean I noticed
that connection also you've seen the
evidence of the eye
not the evidence of words and of
churches and all the rest
about it I mean I've I've almost quoted
well that what he said and that's been
the spirit of sense book two Galileo
showed up in the second book and Galileo
Saturn gets in every book it's about the
it's about empirical evidence of the of
his eyes and uh he is just a piece he's
just beyond everybody he's a you know a
mutation of a mutation this is so ESO
incredible he was pretty good I I do I
do admit that and
I mean there's a flip side right I mean
there are graphic choices that as you
alluded to kind of make things worse
kind of hide what you care about and one
of the other things again going back to
the truth issue that I noticed in
reading the books is this idea that good
graphic design just flows naturally from
Clear thinking about what are the causal
relationships what are the variables
that matter like if you really think
super duper clearly maybe your graphics
will pop out the right way is that an
exaggeration or do you think that's more
or less right this is from uh the green
book of the with the dog on the cover
beautiful evidence and I wrote exactly
about that the purpose of an Evidence
presentation is to assist thinking
that's the key thing thus presentation
should be constructed to assist with the
fundamental intellectual tasks of
reasoning about evidence
describing the data making multivariate
comparisons understanding causality
integrating and diversity of evidence
and documenting the analysis those are
the principles of seeing evidence but
they are also right now just turned into
principles of analytical design hmm the
point of a display is to assist the
viewers the reasoning about it I can
tell you what reason email data is I
turn them into design principles so your
design principles are don't show the
data show multivariabeness show
mechanism causality show an integration
of different kinds of evidence and
provide documentation
this is a very powerful idea that people
don't think about don't realize they
talk about you know why we should use
this method whether we should use both
things and stuff no you go deep down
you're trying to support the thinking of
the viewer and understanding the data
and I can tell you what data thinking is
and turn them into principles this is a
it's it's a big idea because it's making
now a more of a science of this these
are principles of of scientific inquiry
as well too when you're showing that
that and so the principles this is the
ground principle of analytical design
the principles of analytical design are
designed from the principles of
analytical thinking and people don't act
like that they say oh hey we can do
donographics we can do donut Graphics
now
well how does that help the thinking of
the fuel does it testify to causality
does it make comparisons does it still
tell the truth and and so it it makes it
a completely different thing rather than
oh the New Orleans donut Graphics in it
it gets to be the field now
unfortunately of data visualization is
becoming
more about itself
than about helping people understand
data it's like the economics department
is about economics not about the economy
that these things become about
themselves and this is what's happening
in the packages and they're comparing
each other and they make you know they
they often you know get the lowest
common denominator so everybody has a
donut and I think that's a sin
here my advice
for everybody in the the 200th
publication of logistic regression is
um that every major graphic should have
a package insert with it like drugstore
pharmaceutical drugs and that they have
warnings
um for example uh never make a causal
inference from logistic progression
regressive multivariate okay and that's
uh that is so serious that there's a
black box around it from the FBA
I I wrote I wrote that up in my new book
and that should come box plots for
example are an enormous censoring of
data it's called binning and it's
two-dimensional binning when you have a
road box plots and they drug companies
hide stuff all the time with box plots
just show the data dots
didn't say because we have high
resolution screen cell we can see the
data we don't have to use these summary
things and so the Box plus things don't
don't trust anybody who's using them
because they have Cherry Picked those
like crazy they choose the bins
they choose the fact that there's a box
plot and the confined fake breaks turns
ups and downs which are require a whole
lot more data to model that to to have
to to go up into you know start having a
polynomial
thing instead of just a straight a
straight line
and it's uh and so you get these cheap
things there's a plateau that happens at
this point when they're taking the drug
you know and we have to add a whole lot
more there
um the thing I've most discovered from a
viewer's point of view
um is most strongly in the new book uh
where I spend 40 pages on medical
research from a statistical side and
we've got we've got to be inherently
deeply skeptical
of human research because of the
revocation crisis because of all the
false papers and Medicine of a lot of
cheating with the West with the block
the I don't know if you know about this
the reading of blood uh Western blot
tests and they photoshop
the same blots in several times and in
some molecular biology journals it's uh
the the Photoshop shows up in like four
percent of the published papers oh yeah
okay really making things
and so I used to believe very strongly I
did quantitative political economy and
watch some predictions and all that kind
of stuff and it's uh and I believed in a
more I was doing it and and uh
thankfully most of my papers got
replicated
I didn't see that much
um but the fact that it's medical
research where there's so much their
lives at stake and the fact that in this
country
uh it's the only place in the world
where tremendous amounts of money are
made from sick people hmm and from fudge
Zeta
and the FDA doesn't do all that well uh
then they fight a losing battle because
anybody who's a good biostatistician is
going to work for a drug company and
it's a break big it's an enormous it's a
public health problem yeah the cheating
is cheating and medical research is a
public health problem and should be
treated like a public health problem and
I wouldn't have said that 10 years ago
or from all my other stuff I I was much
more thought that numbers would you know
help bring us the truth and that's true
um it's it's easy to although it's easy
to lie with numbers but it's even easier
to lie with words
that's a good quote I like that you see
the lies better yeah than with words
um uh but but uh that really of course
might because it can you know skepticism
strongly about the
routine falsity of of a lot of research
on human beings you did you did a very
in-depth analysis that I learned a lot
from uh of the space shuttle disasters
and there I would say that it wasn't
greed or an attempt to
um lie but just people went a little
astray in how they presented information
and it with terrible consequences could
you explain like to the people who don't
know about this example uh what went
wrong I weren't uh in uh the third book
I have the Challenger which was I
basically have Richard feynman's take on
Challenge and uh I wish I could I was
that's sharper it was really something
and he tells a great story about it in
one of the you know yeah uh but my own
independent work was on
um the um and the second accident uh the
uh the the Challenger
um and I got right after it went down
I got all the fly so it was injured
um uh when um uh
uh at launched when a piece of foam
broke and hit the wing from the launch
and made a whole size of a basketball
and flew for two weeks with the hole in
its wing because there's no air up there
who cares yeah who cares yep and they
knew there was a problem
they may have known quite well by nobody
ever says but it may have been that a
spy plane took a picture of that one but
they don't want to express the
resolution you know say what the
resolution in the system sure but they
they knew there was a problem
and they did a Engineers on about the
fifth day did a big PowerPoint
presentation I got that about a week
after the Columbia went down I got it
via a uh information you know federal
government information thing the
reporter had done and I got the slides
and I don't know anything about rocket
science but I know a lot about the
relationship between evidence and
conclusions and
that wasn't what they were doing was
perfectly clear of the spot
um uh and I take with the key slide
apart and
you know they're in trouble
because they're measuring things in
cubic inches
trouble right there
there's a fan of the two two cell two
things crashed into Mars because of
right nine if that's right there but
these guys who are in cubic anxious but
on one slide they abbreviated cubic
inches three different ways wow if they
were sophomores at MIT and the graduate
student was grading their paper
graduate student would write on the
thing have you thought about
um have you thought about
um uh insurance sales as a career
[Laughter]
because that it's just it's so it's you
know it's it's just a sign of
something's really wrong here
that that they can't get units of
measurement right into in three three
different ways of writing on one page
you know and none of them were inches
cubed they were in CU and just you know
amateur yeah and they they have some
models and they test it and so but it
all gives its gives it away right there
that like this is they they don't they
don't have the material to to make a
decision that everything is okay that's
what they said everything's okay
and it was right there if you saw it you
know especially if you knew it was an
accident but it's absolutely so I did
that on my own I got a hit call from
Boeing saying that they they had
trademark on this or copyright or
something and I said well it was gone by
a you know government thing so
um and the commission that investigated
it published in their final report which
is the 100 page summary of all this
stuff uh my analysis to that slide and
it said we've got to stop engineering by
PowerPoint and it turns out all the
documentation of every project at Nasa
is done in PowerPoint slides there's no
technical reports they used to do
beautiful technical reports they were
famous sure you know like 10 pages and
stuff and so they use it as a general
attack on engineering by PowerPoint but
the point for me is that these the
shuttle people investigating who are a
pretty fancy group investigating the
accident picked up on what I said well
and I don't know anything about rocket
science but I know what the hell I have
a more powerful skill but I can tell the
difference you know between the
relationship the Rel I know about I can
understand the relationship between
evidence and conclusion and that's a
different thing than knowing rocket
science
because it's Mo it's more General yeah
broader
that's right it's very interesting
because I know that you know you've said
you've criticized PowerPoint before very
trenchantly and I'll I'll confess I use
PowerPoint all the time when I give
talks but I guess uh I would never think
to use it to sort of share information
as the text that makes sense yeah yeah
yeah
um I had a wonderful thing happen very
early on about PowerPoint which I didn't
hear about until 15 years later
so the PowerPoint essay comes out and it
has the Columbia in it and among other
things and was called the cognitive
style of PowerPoint and it had a picture
of Stalin giving a talk
and and the people down below you know
of all the soldiers waiting down below
making remarks about his bad PowerPoint
and I somebody somebody read that essay
before it was published and said why
don't you say what you should do instead
of just saying you know bad PowerPoint
and I first I got kind of stylist my job
sought to rescue PowerPoint and I
thought well but I should rescue my
audience my people
and so I wrote one page in which is
every meeting should begin with the
handout that uses sentences
um two to six pages using sentences no
bullets and every meeting begins with
the 30-minute reading period movie
and
it's how I taught the confused uh ivy
league undergraduates but we actually
had to think in class in class oh my
goodness in class we had to think that
was yes they were used to scrub they
were very good at scribbling notes but
they had and so if I had a proof on the
board I would pass the proof out so they
didn't have to take notes and then they
can annotate how I got from step three
to step four you know Mark that up it's
like and and so they weren't in doing
stenography anymore you know so a few
months after that came out Jeff Bezos
and his uh direct assistant
were flying rooting aloud my essay on
PowerPoint and they saw that set of
sentences six pages
and they immediately had the opposite it
they threw out PowerPoint and the
highest level decision making was made
by the there was no there was no
presentation there was no rehearsal or
no slide there was the six six pager
people can read there faster than you
can talk and so I have my courses people
got all five books and there was reading
Walter in the class I mean talk a lot
too but we would stop and read these two
pages and I'd talk about it and so on
and so it was back and forth of them
reading different mode and they can read
they can skip things they're not
interested so you were slides everybody
has the same slide at once and it's
controlled by the but with reading
everybody in the room can use their own
priorities and their own sense of
relevance with that and so all the work
of preparation went into the report and
a team might even do that six-pager then
they discuss it for an hour and a half
and he says it gave us an enormous
competitive advantage and he said these
they wrote about this
15 years later it gave us a tremendous
competitive Advantage an order of
magnitude competitive Advantage they
said this method uh that everything that
we want on went through this method and
they just went batshit
I didn't know about I was feeling
bullied but Microsoft and Boeing and
stuff and you know the people doing
saying bad things about me and stuff and
here Jeff Bezos was you know the Amazon
was doing this and thinking it was the
greatest thing in the world it was
unbelievable and I would have felt very
comfortable and not so paranoid and
threatened if I'd known you know I could
have told that story but it didn't come
out or maybe they could have slid you
one percent for the profits
that's another point which is I
patterned a medical interface a long
long time ago but I decided to make
everything open source I thought about
sparklines
doing that and I had a patent lawyer who
could who said they could do anything
they could patent anything Microsoft
patented sparklines but they didn't uh
and they use it as a trademark
bullet but my view is I'm open source
yeah and also I've enjoyed just fine on
all these books and all the stages I
don't I don't need I don't like that I I
like the ideas I'm so happy to get the
ideas out yeah and so hearing that
Amazon was using this to great success
and lots of other people that you know
that that made me so happy
well it had consequences and the thing
about meetings uh I mean this this goes
a little bit beyond
the visual display of information right
I mean this is this is a kind of a way
of thinking right I mean and then the
PowerPoint critique gets into that as
well so is there a future book that has
nothing to do with data visualization
um well you just exposed it I have uh
volume six
uh and uh don't mean to give it away I
can tell you the title
presenting analyzing data slash
information
smarter Communications shorter meetings
content credibility Clarity efficiency
honesty oh very good part two how to
evaluate presentations
how to make presentations so it's both
from the consumer and the producer point
of view see so they're both thinking
about credibility and content concealer
and producer and then the second uh
piece of this two chapter thing is data
analysis visualization and the truth
and this is a sort of short course in ET
okay those those titles report it turns
out presentation means kind of
everything you could say it's like a
medical report you could tell it's you
know but uh it's it's focused on both
the production and consumption and the
interplay between the producer and
consumer well it's it's it's crucially
important in the modern world right
there's so much information so much
content our attention is so very
important and there's there has to be
huge inefficiencies that we haven't
quite figured out yet I mean I know when
I go hear someone give a lecture seminar
colloquium and physics and it's an hour
long I will absolutely learn more from
talking to them one-on-one for five or
ten minutes than I will from an
hour-long presentation and because you
can control yes you have I guess so
what's relevant I guess so so I mean but
is there how do you how do you make that
scale I mean I don't always have uh
access to the presenter myself for even
10 minutes
um I write about efficiency it's in the
title and
one of the principles is
um
show up early and finish early
the presenter show Burley chap people up
get from getting get them to start
reading the document yeah and finish
your role they'll be thrilled no one
ever wished the meeting longer thrilled
the other thing
is a good six-page or can pretty well do
it
I have thought times of hey read this
and to say a little bit in my class I do
that it's all there read it they can
read twice as fast at least as you can
talk and they can choose what they read
instead of the damn bullets they can
choose what's important to them and
everybody's reading differently
that it's it's a tremendous advantage to
instead of cooking through the slides
too fast too slow too boring they can
skip paragraphs they can go oh you're a
slow and what right they can mark it up
they can you know they can read it twice
they can check you know something back
they can mark it up and then oh there's
School humans let me see now this was
good this is good I don't have to worry
about that so and you know you could at
some places uh say anybody want to
discuss this people won't dare put their
hand no no but except people who always
right they are some who always do yeah
yeah
I have a strategy about people who ask
questions which is uh sort of this the
you think about the priorities of all
the other people in the audience
the person they most like to hear talk
are themselves
I agree secondly they'd like to hear me
the people that least like to hear talk
are their fellow audience members so on
that principle I decide I'll talk you
can do handle the questions in maybe
under 20 people it's more of a
discussion like that you know in a
little classroom or maybe 25 but it gets
when you if you get over if you get over
30 you have now have people sitting in
front who are people who ask questions
at everything you know they're
professional and it's often I they have
some other cause and you know uh or it's
obvious or you know it does and we're
wasting the time of you know the other n
minus the N minus one people in the room
especially if Anna's big you know if
there's 300 people in a lecture you just
can't do it
um it uh it's not a discussion it's
these little mini speeches often
um or they saw maybe one in ten has some
kind of grievance say I've used
PowerPoint for 20 years
[Laughter]
um that strategy I just mentioned is in
in this essay about the audience and
questions and about the priorities of
the audience I think that's a very
convincing argument about priorities of
your audience who would you like to hear
talking you can't talk yourself they
want to hear the presenter yeah it's a
very it's a very big question for the
modern world how we share information
and how we choose and what our time
scales are and our methods and I don't
think that we're very good at it yet so
I'm glad to see you pushing to at least
try to get better in that direction
you've got to uh because there's so much
stuff you've got so much stuff the other
thing is there's some good research on
ignoring things oh yeah and being
self-aware of ignoring and being
self-delibately ignoring this
um I wish I could do that when I look at
Twitter
[Laughter]
don't not that word don't say I can
throw away a whole afternoon
you know poking around and it's kind of
interesting it's just interesting to
know just interesting enough oh how are
the lawyers doing you know they have a
game tonight I know
and and uh it's requires it's often
beyond my self-discipline yeah yeah I
got I charged it away from my bed okay
good I put my phone in the kitchen we
have to trick ourselves yeah
well and the relationship between Art
and Science here is fascinating because
as a as a scientist you know I like to
think that a theoretical physicist we're
trying to construct a theory a model
we're working toward that but as an
artist it's more of a craft there's you
know rules for this or suggestions or
whatever and I'm wondering if you think
of your own work in visualizing
information as being
articulations of a single underlying
Theory or as just learning in a more
piecemeal way and trying to use our
judgment along the way
um the smart alec answer and half true
is that inspiration
is for amateurs
and the rest of us just go to the studio
every day and go to work
and I see my art as
uh but what has in common with real
science is intense seeing and
understanding that intensity brings some
understanding and then ability to change
and work from it and so on and
everything serious requires
um unless you're supremely talented like
Picasso requires
um uh a uh a series of steps of change
of discovering the material in art as as
you you have an idea
and I can tell within about half an hour
whether it's just going to work out or
not and I have learned if I can't find
promise for the half an hour as I call
my backhoe operator in and say bury that
because I don't it's not going to work
it's going to waste time that you know I
could I know this is going to work it's
not working now but I know it will and
um and then it's trying to avoid words
of not saying it looks like
Picasso it looks like Stonehenge it's a
piece of stone and so I see it for its
traits not it's not what it's its name
but its color its texture and the very
special thing about
sculpture and about physics is air is a
material
space absolutely you know you don't want
to do things in that in that world are
are our sculptures errors of material
and this and space is a material for in
physics yeah and that's uh I'm not quite
sure what that means but well it is
thinking about errors and material
that's what sculptors do when I'm
working with my colleagues on a piece
probably half our comments are about
airspace
and it's it's like figure ground on
paper that's that's trivial that's just
floutland design that's that's I wrote a
whole book about Escape called this
basically escaping flatland and
that's where I knew I was graphic design
was easy because it was a lot of fun
really hard stuff is you've got errors
in material and it's a vague and it
changes from every perspective on every
kind of light and every kind of Sky of
you know and and whether it's raining or
not and so there's such a multiplicity
of things out there to sort among and
make decisions about
um but it's I don't call it it's not
craft it's a kind of of the technical
name of doing a piece is uh disjointed
incrementalism okay
otherwise known as muddling through
the small steps they're kind of separate
steps it's it isn't muddling through
it's trying things out uh it has a clear
stopping point
um in the work I find that at the end of
the the first kind of ending
the end of maybe a day or a couple of
days of work I think it's really great
and I believe that fairly strongly and I
get up the next morning and see three
things wrong and I'm willing to change
my mind but there's something I have to
I have to believe in it for a while and
and defend it you know yeah and and then
gather myself with uh fresh eyes
sometimes the next morning
um or the maybe even the next day and we
said we got to do this now and got to
try that
um and and that's especially the case
because I locate the art that is I have
234 Acres of my own shows only my
sculpture and we have backhoes and we
make ridges and no other artist has
control of the space of the land Richard
Sarah gets a few hundred to maybe 500
square feet in front of a building laid
out by an architect and they say that's
where you're going to put your piece and
this I have control of the landscape of
the trees there are seven ridges ups and
downs the location we can change it I
usually will change it maybe after six
months or some better space and all of
that is now completely changing the air
too
there is a material and so it's just
like in self-publishing my books or have
complete control there's no bureaucracy
there's no uh thanks to the books I've
been able to pay for all the sculpture
stuff yeah
there's some there I do big landscape
pieces you know they're the marketer
landscape abstract landscape uh is work
to market for for Canadian experimental
poetry it's not a big Market
which is actually good because I'm free
of pitching to rich people about why
they should do it good it so that's the
same thing with making the books there's
no bureaucracy there's no editor there's
no editorial board there's no uh I I
choose the printer I worked directly
with so it's all this Hands-On
thing that is combined with the mind and
those are those two it's those two
things that have really helped me
because it's there's though there are
there are no middle people yeah they're
no assistant Deans
uh universities have become bizarre in
the last 15 20 years
uh with the deputy assistant Provost and
an endless of they I have a law of
University growth which is the doubling
time of the bureaucracy is 12 years
during which time the number of faculty
and students remains constant it's
astonishing the rate of that yeah well
the doubly time that's it that's
something yeah that's right I do want to
give you a chance to to talk about one
other artistic thing which is the
Feynman diagram oh yes oh I love that
all the finding diagrams in your new
book and you know the audience can't see
but as I'm as we're talking to each
other there are five men diagrams behind
you well what is it that make I love
finding diagrams but why do you love
them as much
um I grew up in Beverly Hills or I went
to high school and uh I never knew
Feynman I never went to a talk but
um a couple of my friends went to
Caltech I found out about his physics
textbook the three volume
um yeah and
so that was kind of introduction
and he has a very the QED book is very
good it's mainly in English it's four
lectures he gave and there are lots of
Feynman diagrams and they're a miracle
about uh you know you get the 17th
significant digit accurate in theory in
practice and so on and so that went in
the green the the fourth book Allah and
Fineman and then I here's how I started
making the sculptures
I made a huge rocket 80 feet long with
an Airstream trailer
on the end
and it's like in Lost position only it's
at an angle at my it's the sculpture of
mine big sculpture rocket science three
and it has lights inside and rotating TV
antenna in an Airstream trailer
with wheels and all this and it's quite
Frankish and I showed it in front of
fermilab along with feynman's Van I paid
ten thousand dollars to have finding the
fans repaired they brought it in and
they brought my this my Airstream
trailer in which I didn't think they
didn't ring the rocket out that's 80
feet long and put it in front of the
Fermi lab when I lived I had a big show
of things and the department of energy
the uh Cabinet member came and loves
them and so they bought a bunch of them
and they've their stormy lab I first
used them on that Airstream trailer
it's going
you know to some other place and the
aliens or the the people whoever they
are far away they're not going to
understand what the NASA logo was or uh
the flag
um no wonder sound find one diagrams
interesting and they'll say the people
inside are pretty smart
because it's reversal it's Universal and
you know there's the the while we find
the diagrams all kinds of places because
they're based on nature's laws and some
days it'll just a little code of it and
and so on and so it and so it was a
lovely prank and I just put three find
the diagrams on the side and they cast
Shadows on the aluminum thing and it
looked beautiful they are also beautiful
that's the thing right and this turned
out to be the G minus two or something
thanks and it was came out just a year
or two ago that was an accident I I
chose these because they were tenth
order and they were the coolest ones and
a guy had printed you know like 500 of
them if thousands of dollars but these
are I believe tenth order Feynman
diagrams and it happened to come up with
the you know the something that was
minus two G minus two of the MU one yeah
a way to find new physics right yes
um and I showed that at uh at Fermi lab
about three or four years ago and uh
that was kind of scary because you know
they actually knew what these things
were you know I understood them
um and one of them said uh uh complained
about one of the things for you know
that was maybe on not not appropriate if
you know he said what's what's that and
I had prepared and uh
um and I had said uh well you guys
divide by zero
[Music]
but we divide Zero by zero so it's maybe
it's okay
I should have said that okay
uh uh and then famous Hunters first say
the Nobel Foundation took them on or the
Nobel Library some that uh took him on
some tour they went to Hong Kong and
then covet came yeah okay went for his
100th 100th anniversary assignment right
and that was uh I didn't go to the
opening unfortunately I it was just too
much yeah I'd already seen them but the
pictures are wonderful and that that
just made me so happy you know they were
out there and you know and the The
Secret of them is to make them raise
them about two two to three inches off
the surface then they cast Shadows yeah
and they're the most amazing things
because you have a couple of
perpendicular things coming out that
pull them away which create now a a
space going backwards to the wall from
the metal to the wall by those posts and
there's the look The the Shadows look
three-dimensional because of the light
and then of course the Shadows change as
the sun goes by and so they just are
totally alive and always different
because the Shadows are strong often and
along with the Silvery part and and this
is a sign of a really good art piece was
and you've got all kinds of amazing
things for free that's my favorite
expression about a piece of art it's not
true of all that is things you didn't
plan on at all but when it was raining
it did something magical or when there
was butterlight with sunrise and sunset
it did something magical with the
butterlight of Sunrise and sunks up and
I call that this is all for free
that's such a wonderful thing to make a
piece
that you can say that about you can't
say that about you can say that about a
lot of outdoor pieces because you've got
rain and Shadow and the light and
there's rotating all all of that and all
those were for free and and completely
on
unfathomable until you actually see them
you know the combination of a shadow but
it's also raining and or dogs running by
and there's this and that and that's a
way of a good piece of art and you never
say that against against the flat on the
way
it's the dead Spain the optical
experience you may be able to see
different things someone but not this
stuff you get for free every day you see
us so this gives you free fresh eyes I
have a flat painting say on the in
inside after oh a month I don't even see
it anymore yeah I have to move it these
things the pieces out here are they're
always alive they're always different
I'm always happy to see them yeah and I
I like rain the best it's a brain makes
the the rust and the iron and the stone
you know warm have this nice warm
moisture luscious color to them plus the
stone looks great right you know when
it's wet well I mean this this forces me
to ask one one more thing then then we
can wrap it up which is the importance
of the time domain uh to everything that
you're talking about uh I mean you're
making the point that these kinds of
works of art even though they're
stationary they interact with their
environment in such a way that at
different times they give you different
experiences but you've also really
emphasized even in the data
visualization world the importance of
when you collect the data and the
importance of when you present the data
and maybe this is yet another Frontier
that people need to think about I think
the best idea in the new book
is the following you never learn more
about a process
than when you watched the original
measurements being made
that came from a great applies
classification with a lovely name
cuspert Daniel
uh who did industrial statistics and so
add a little more sulfur and you know
step 34 if that's industrial and he do
little stirrments and it was incredibly
smart MIT
Etc and he did applied work and made it
was a famous consultant for on drugs but
on Industrial processes and we wrote a
paper together about uh the FDA and
he told me that and he said here's an
example
General Electric put pcbs in the Hudson
River and they spent billions trying to
make up for it and they had to do
testing every day of how through how
good the water was and report to the EPA
and so let's go out of the little boat
to make a test and it's a guy in a
little small boat and he's got kind of a
you know a cup on the end of a stick and
he leans over out of the boat to take a
sample and he leans over to the side
where the water is cleaning
the statisticians maliciously call that
was sampling to pleads
the only time when you can see that is
when you're watching the measurement
right
right you're there and I have come to
play when many people's backyards I
watched three surgeries at the Cleveland
Clinic
um One open heart
um two robotic I've solved NASA's toys
play other people's backyard and I did a
section in about being at the point of
measurement in the book and I did an
interview about once every six weeks
with a ICU and emergency room nurse for
four years before five years now before
the epidemic because she was my
hairdresser and after an hour and a half
I would just ask her a question another
question just listening prompting
and see when there's when the system
variance is zero you can use it you
could you need an N of one
okay that's that's a cool point so she
was talking about uh drawing blood she
talking about all drawing blood there
isn't much variation you're going to
hear most of the most everything in this
one sample of size one okay and that's a
very good way and and it's accidental
she's come to me it's not any kind of
drawing you know it's not any kind of
cherry picking is just convenient it's
just and
I learned so much from her of the
general system of how it worked I'm not
there in the in the ICU with her but I
am asking questions emergency room now
and you know you think okay this is
happening in every emergency room in the
country you know they're totally jammed
up and these things happen and they're
always filled with Pyrenees and and
stuff and it's better than chosen
anecdotes see because we're having this
Observer who's just telling us what's
going on you know and that I think is
the best idea in the whole book and it's
it's in my spirit of being Hands-On yeah
and and instead of these guys writing
the 500th way to do such and such of
just the regression is what everybody
uses go out and watch how this stuff's
measurement get out of the field and
watch the measurements and you're you
know the scales will fall from your eyes
you're assuming these observations are
independent
there's a saying in physics That No One
Believes a theory more than the theorist
who proposed it and no one is more
skeptical of data than the
experimentalist who collected it
I like that I like that because they
know the dirty stuff exactly I mean even
that's probably the most important
reason why we do labs in undergraduate
physics so you know that it's not a
completely clean uh painless experience
to collect that data there's some
there's some things that happen that you
should be aware of it's because you
often a person doing it often knows the
right answer
um
that's the
um I understood you know the you're
seeing measurement here right right from
the start in a way yep yep well uh
Edward Tuffy thanks so much I think
you've given us a lot to think about and
new ways of thinking in a very
information Rich world that we live in
today oh well thank you I I love doing
this good thanks bye-bye good take care
bye
[Music]
mama